à mazamet est ce que tu penses que cyril
hanouna une plus belle carrière que toi
11 et sous les photographies qui nous
dit ça c'est une question compliquée à
banon se sent plein qu'on a aujourd'hui
oui évidemment alors moi je suis pas
prêt honnêtement si je suis très honnête
dans ma j'ai fait une plus longue
carrière que cyril j'ai présenté plus
d'émissions que cyril j'ai eu des très
beaux succès mais il ajouté toujours dit
cyril et la réussit il a réussi une
vraie performance et c'est pas pour lui
pour lui tirer les boules c'est pas pour
le shérif pompéi l'aï là il a conseillé
deux choses d'abord il a eu l'adhésion
du public
avec cette émission et ça mais
maintenant ça fait près de sept ans il a
réussi financièrement et il a réussi à
concilier les deux en restant j'ai le
sentiment est le même mec la même
personne donc je pense qu'il avoue et
surtout il a réussi une chose qu on est
très peu dans ce métier je pense qu'il
est le seul à avoir réussi il s'est
totalement affranchie vous ne dirait pas
le contraire
deux écoles des codes et de l'autorité
ce mec là il a il a un truc de qu'on a
tous rêvé de faire c'est de pouvoir dire
à son patron
c'est en mer
[Rires]
c'est belleville c4 c'est comme ça moi
je veux dire la vérité je pense
franchement quand on producteur je pense
j'ai une belle carrière que toi mais en
tant qu'animateur je pense qu'à une bien
plus belle carrière comment puisque tu
as fait des émissions qui ont fait des
records d'audience culte et a fait des
émissions sur les défis et devenez des
audiences que je ne ferai jamais donc
pour moi tu es un des challenges savait
rien tu es dans le top 3 des animateurs
voilà qui ont fait les plus grosses
carrière et qui ont amené tête c'est toi
qui a présenté les missions qui restera
culte love story
voilà donc je te le dise voilà donc je
te dis moi ce que je pense en tout cas
et vous êtes plus jeunes ne s'est pas
passé sept ans et maire du mans merde
assez sur las pour que excusez moi mais
je ferai jamais ce qu'il a fait